we're told that mika can eat 21 hot dogs
in 66 minutes she wants to know how many
minutes m would it take her to eat 35
hot dogs if she can keep up the same
pace
so a big clue is the same pace
and i have to remove a hair from my
tongue all right
a big a big clue is the same pace that
means that the hot dogs
hot dogs
per minute
per minute
is going to be constant is always going
to be the same
always the same
always the same because this is
essentially the pace her hot dogs per
minute are going to stay the same it's
going to stay at the same pace so we it
tells us that she can eat 21 hot dogs in
66 minutes
so her hot dogs per minute at least up
here it's 21 hot dogs in 66 minutes so
it's 21 hot dogs in 66 minutes
well if her pace is always going to be
the same
well it's going to take her this ratio
over here is going to be the ratio
between 35 hot dogs and however long it
takes her to to eat 35 hot dogs so once
again hot dogs per minute or go it has
to be a constant because it's going to
be the same pace hot dogs per minute if
it if it takes 21 hot dogs take 66
minutes 35 hot dogs take m minutes these
two ratios are going to be the same
we're dealing with a proportional
relationship that's going to be
happening at the same rate and then
we're left with a situation where we
just have to solve for m
and there's a bunch of different ways
that you could tackle this the easiest
way that i can think of doing it is i
like i don't like this m sitting here in
the denominator so let's multiply both
sides by m
let me do that in a different color
so
if i multiply that side by m and then
this side by m
and so what do we get on the left hand
side we have 21 over 66 m
21 over 66 times m
times m
is equal to
is equal to well you divide by m and
multiply by m those are going to cancel
out you're just going to have 35
and now you just have to solve for m and
the best way i can think of doing that
is multiply both sides times the
reciprocal on
both sides times the reciprocal of the
coefficient on the m so let's multiply
both sides by
let's multiply both sides by 66 over 21.
once again i've just swapped the
numerator and the denominator here to
get the reciprocal but i can't just do
it to one side of an equation i have to
do it to both sides otherwise it's not
going to be an equation it's not going
to be equal anymore so times 66
over 21
this is just going to be one you
multiply something times its reciprocal
you're just going to end up with one so
you're going to be left with m
is equal to
now 35 times 66 divided by 21.
well 35 is the same thing as 35 is 5
times 7
and 21 is 3 times 7
so you're multiplying by 7 up here and
here you have a 7 in the denominator
you're dividing by 7 so they're going to
cancel out so this is going to simplify
to
5 times
66
over 3 and then we could simplify it
even more because 66 is the same thing
as 3 times 22
3 times 22 and so you have a 3 in the
numerator you're multiplying by 3 and a
3 in the denominator dividing by 3 3
divided by 3 is 1. so you're left with 5
times 22 which is 110
so it would take her m minutes to eat 35
hot dogs at the same pace
now when some of you might have tackled
it you might have had a different
equation set up here instead of thinking
of hot dogs per minute you might have
thought about minutes per hot dog and so
in that situation if you thought in
terms of minutes per hot dog you might
have said okay look it took micah
66 minutes to eat 20 to eat 21 hot dogs
and it's going to take her m minutes to
eat 35 hot dogs and if it's the same
base
then these two rates are going to be
equal they have to be the same pace
and so then you can solve for m and
actually this one's easier to solve for
m you just multiply both sides by 35
multiply both sides
by 35 and you're left with on the right
hand side you're left with just an m and
on the left hand side same same idea
you're taking 35 you have 35 times 66
21st which we already figured out is
110. so 110 is equal
is equal to m so once again multiple
ways to tackle it but it's important
that we we got the the same answer